et vous noté ces parties indique t
madame de rénal l'adie de point à la
ligne
ouvrez les guillemets pharisiens 21,0 me
convient il y a encore deux ans vanessa
caillou était professeur de français
alors bien sûr dans son premier
spectacle impossible de ne pas en parler
vous avez terminé donc une petite pause
et je notais qu'est ce que vous écrivez
madame t'inquiète foulée jours en tout
propre
tous les jours il se passe des trucs
énormes donc tu peux faire j'aurais pu
faire deux heures de spectacle un an là
dessus mais bon après j'ai concentré et
j'ai pas raconté pierre parce que le
pire les gens croiraient pas une heure
d'énergie à revendre et pourtant vanessa
keyyo est sur scène une feignasse celles
qui aimeraient être devant sa télé mais
qui a un boulot un enfant annexes et des
factures à payer c'est quand même un
petit peu autobiographique à la base
faut le dire et après c'est le quotidien
fait l'observation est ce que tu sais ça
c'est j'observe mon enfant je pense
qu'elle est
je vais chez gyneco il arrive des trucs
enfin un sketch parce que les femmes
disent les hommes aussi parce que ça
parle aux hommes aussi évidemment en
sortant ses mais c'est fin c'est ma vie
que
donc oui en fait on se rend compte qu'on
a plein de points communs tous après ce
titre est un peu un but dès la mi temps
vanessa caillou crocs des instants de
vie de tous les jours des situations
parfois il vaut mieux en rire et bien du
temps c'est tout cet oubli son côté
grave le train dans le bus le soir quand
à personne de l'arabe ou alors juste toi
est le sosie d'emile louis